the reason there's going to be a billion
motivational views today on YouTube is
that people love the feeling of being
motivated they don't like putting in the
work to do something about the feeling
[Music]
morning
whatever time could be thank you so much
thank you soon
we're not in New York City anymore
losers are losers for a reason Dirac
life
people allow motions to get the best of
them
no room for emotion and the big leagues
passion yes but being clouded by
insecurities you tomorrow think that
there's a there's a lot of different
things we could talk about first I want
to get clarity you know when you say
engagement we want to grow engagement
across all platforms are you actually
referring to engagement metrics or are
you referring to top-line follow count
so the answer the answer to your
question Neal and Jess and team is
there's a lot of different things you
could do I think at the end of the day
did I lose him oh hey guys sorry about
that I'm back I was uh I'm up in Lake
Placid I'm actually about to give a
keynote speech in the in the stadium
where the us done the Soviet Union in
1980 I'm excited that have the biggest
audiences in the world and then really
sitting back and understanding who what
our relationships are with them how
we're structured and then coming up with
the big creative campaign to drive
follow count I think could be a massive
win
yeah what's going on with that it
doesn't get firm until the yeah but but
the fluctuation and that is very small
no I mean let me give an example the the
likelihood of currency going up 30
percent in that period is one person one
point zero zero one percent and what and
think about what that actually means you
know it means something if you're buying
Bordeaux at 80 bucks but if you're
buying something at six bucks and it
goes to 780 it's a it's a it's the stuff
we're buying right now it's not gonna
matter
but in my melody but I've been sober too
long has me promethazine I need someone
to lean on swear not to trust again
that's just my innocence hi career for
such a pleasure yeah how are things good
[Music]
this is so cool
this is such a legendary sleep
I made it good how are you good I'm
ready for the manager Chun how are you
is really such a pleasure how are you
thank you pleasure thanks for having it
what what for you guys would be most
exciting for me to focus on it you know
is that the motivational part is a
tactical part like I do feel that people
that are attracted to your business
model rely way too much on you the
person that's willing to sign up for
your thing or a business that is
franchisees are things that nature
whether it's McDonald's or it's the guy
who started something yesterday he's got
three franchisees the DNA of the person
that signs up for a franchisee like I
would never do that my intention is you
would never do that so it's an
interesting thing there's a part of them
that's 90% entrepreneur and 10% like
what's the mother ship gonna do for me
and I'm always trying to focus them on
like forget what the mother ship is
gonna do you're in full control if you
spend a minute on what the mother ship
does that's a minute away from what you
could be controlling you signed up for
this for a reason
thank you brother what's your name
Justin Justin is neat you wanna start
over
yeah can you make it to a friend yeah
Chris Chris is gonna go Chris
just gotta go on in my one second yeah
thank you thank you I'll be sure to take
care just meet you man
a lot of people excited to see you much
yeah I'm excited
Digital is human it's just scalable
human the fruit yeah you know what I
mean I mean people always like yeah but
you have a real connection with somebody
that you talked to on Twitter I'm like
tell me what the difference is between
that and writing a letter eighty years
ago like yes I do
okay like your job job yeah
so twelve weeks ago I started JT in the
rule weekly Facebook live show and I'm
getting now five to seven hundred views
on Facebook then repurpose it and load
it up on YouTube YouTube with subtitles
blogger send it out I picked up two
comments here in blue s because of that
100% man and it works
listen I know my stuff works I just know
that 99% of the people aren't gonna do
anything with it yeah I can tell you
what to do my screwdriver works but if
you don't go and do it
then that screwdriver sucks [ __ ] I don't
think people understand first of all
I've been talking about this since I
wrote crush it in 2009 this is nothing
new this is just momentum like that like
that phone that's the remote control of
our lives like this is just started like
this isn't he this is here but this is
just the beginning like this only
becomes exponentially far more extreme
I could not be more excited to introduce
our next speaker entrepreneur social
media legend wine connoisseur digital
media group venture capital expense
helicopter number on the hustle and feel
of vaynermedia you guys having LEM and
Gary V please help me welcome Gary
Vaynerchuk since the beginning of time
literally all the way back to the
printing press before we've had this
seismic of a ship have you not
understood what's happened in our
society around the notion of
communication have we not understood
that 10 years ago if you were online
dating you were the weirdest [ __ ]
nerd of all time and now 80% of this
audience is swiping right 24/7 365 what
the [ __ ] is a matter with you you can
get anything answered in the world on a
site called Google in 2 seconds if you
can't read like me you can watch a video
if you love reading not so your [ __ ]
socks off but the reality is how do I do
ads on Instagram takes three minutes
you're just not putting in the effort
because you're trying to do tactics you
haven't made the religious decision that
you understand that the world is
fundamentally changing forever my
friends it's not coming back
we're not going to all sit around and
watch [ __ ] mash it's over
he got into speech hey Katya I meet a
beauty that was a lot of fun thank you
thank you thanks for having me is it go
command how are you thank you better job
yeah you're gonna learn about third
Twitter fall around Thanks
awesome let's do stay well good stuff
thank you so much have a great speech
man thank you brother
I I listen to your podcast on a weekly
basis and I'd be a fool if I didn't take
the time to shake your hand
thank you so much what's your name I'm
Corey Corey where you from Indiana very
nice man yep give it a good conference
so far yeah it's great great you're
welcome
take care of in
talk to you soon take care we're talking
about private label champagne I was like
hey maybe we should do something like
cleco owns orange we should own a color
oh wait a minute maybe we should own
like light blue and go to Tiffany's
style because it speaks to elegance and
that justifies a $40 champagne I'm doing
this for d-roc but you're just gonna be
the recipient on it we've been talking a
lot lately about like the speed in which
I execute I think it comes down to the
reason I'm able to do so much [ __ ] is
because I know that almost everything
except for the five biggest macro issues
if you do a 91 or an 86 or a 79 out of
100 on that issue it's pretty much the
same that score and it's not more
valuable than the time that you dictate
to it that's always what I tell you
about like the main wine offering right
it's like [ __ ] it wouldn't have mattered
and then the uns lighting an hour and a
half debating and really there was gonna
be no difference one way or the other
and if it was it was gonna be so
marginal compared to the value of your
time anyway sorry that's your first
appearance on a ramp jabberin look at
the matrix right now what have you not
created thank you my friend thank you so
much what have you not created or what
is glaring over 5:00 in the matrix yeah
horse let's do it let's do it
yeah there you go Baba stuck this in
and thanks again to doing it take care
say yes I'm getting really great
feedback yeah thank you
take care yeah for sure how you doing
Josh how are you man good Sara Kabira
real pleasure missiles so you go just
got it possible I said apology yes I see
you next time
yeah oh yeah yeah look man I got home
right away thank you man like you the
same thank you
and then today they were like I was
going through like well yesterday we're
going for like the UH who's gonna be
honest I'm still [ __ ] way cool go
okay let's do it Robbie don't do it I
love it thank you
let's get in here alright guys thanks
man wish you well I hear yourself good
luck you man really nice Megan stay well
take care man thanks for love uh we're
gonna have to me that once we lair at
how men what justifies how many we need
you know what I mean once we get that
logic how many cases year we sell how
many cases do we have in stock and the
computer tells you how many you need oh
it's over when it really mathematically
understands that you need three $20
Pinos you know at the end of the day I'm
a retailer I'm just you know the quick
action of b2c versus the long game of
b2b is such a difference between client
library and vaynermedia I get such a
high from the transactions
it's kind of like speaking is instant
feedback it up
eBay selling instant feedback banners
much more long lead time to three months
land a client fascinating differences
both fun and fruitful but like very
different games
all right Brent can you kill it can we
just do the single most important thing
real quick I want to start a podcast and
uh man all right actually know what I
think we would start a podcast we're
gonna produce it at vaynermedia and you
and one of the wine staff members going
to come I'm being dead serious by the
way and I love that and I love that idea
called what are we drinking we're seven
people taste the same wine don't know
what the other people thought and we
just recorded the tasting notes and
that's the show I just think that's
funny yeah and we're gonna do it all
right you gotta go
all right see you bye thank you so much
my friend take care all right welcome
back thank you
oh no listen felt like you know the
reason I said that is there's there's a
reason that guys and gals like me
continue to have audiences because
people want to be motivated to go and do
things or they want to learn tactics to
go and do things but if weather aren't
getting you tactical advice like filters
on snapchat or Facebook ads or Instagram
story collaborations or I'm motivating
you through my words because I
communicate that way for through my
actions seeing this wake up at 5:00
working if everybody who's watching this
actually did something about it and then
went on the course of their version of
it and then they wouldn't be watching
this and I genuinely know at the bottom
of my heart out of all the people that
want to build audiences that I'm the
complete opposite of almost all of them
[Music]
99% of people that produce content like
this that are out there like I am the
business of being that is what they are
I have businesses I have wine library in
vaynermedia I don't need your 14 bucks
for my book want to be in my course or
this and that so I don't need to
monetize so I then genuinely want you to
never watch me again the problem is
every time you guys are posting dealing
times I see on my on my Instagram oh I
needed this today and you know many
times I see that person nine months
later still hanging around
okay there we go
there we go finally finally
if you needed it then take it and do
something about it the reason there's
gonna be a billion motivational views
today on YouTube is that people love the
feeling of being motivated they don't
like putting in the work to do something
about stealing
I hate the motivation me
until you do something about it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]